So, when can we start using 5G?
Well not yet, and according to some analysts, not until 2020.
5G was created years ago and has been talked up ever since,...
...yet it's estimated that even by 2025,...
...the network will still lag behind both 4G and 3G...
...in terms of global mobile connections.
Its mainstream existence faces multiple hurdles.
The most significant of these of course is cost.
According to some experts,...
...5G could cause network operators to tear up their current business models...
...for it to make business sense.
In the UK, for example,...
...3G and 4G networks were relatively cheap to set up...
...because they were able to roll out on existing frequencies,...
...on the country's radio spectrum.
For 5G to work properly however, it needs a frequency with much bigger bandwidth,...
...which would require brand new infrastructure.
Some analysts believe that the extensive building and running costs...
...will force operators to share the use and management of the mobile network.
This has been less of an obstacle for countries like China...
...who are taking a more coherent approach.